كاثي كونغ هي احد الناجين من مرض السارج
اذ كانت تعيش في اشد الاحياء تعرضا لموجه
الوباء في هونغ كونج كما اصيب اكثر من 300
شخص من جيران كاثي
بالمرض لم اكن اعلم ان حالتي كانت خطه
ومخيفه جدا الى ان تم صرفي من المستشفى
وعند وصولي الى المجمع وجدت ان اغلب
المحال التجاريه المجاوره للسكن كانت
مغلقه والهدوء يخيم على المنطقه بخلاف
الايام
الاعتياديه وكانت الشوارع في مناطق اخرى
من هونغ كونج مهجوره رغم انها كانت
بالعاده مزدحمه اضافه الى ارتداء المشاه
اقنعه لحمايتهم الامر الذي زاد من حجم
الطلب عليها حتى ان المستشفيات اصبحت تجد
صعوبه في الحصول عليها لم نستعد حينها
بالشكل المناسب لاننا اعتقدنا بان المرض
سينتشر بشكل محدود ثم اكتشفنا انتشاره في
مجمع الحدائق السكنيه كما كان هناك شح في
مخزون هذه
الاقنعه
الدكتور سيام شو اخصائي تنفس في مستشفى
المسيحيون المتحدون وهو المكان الذي عالج
العديد من مصابي مرض سارز في مجمع الحدائق
السكنيه رغم ان الدكتور شو وزملائه لم
يكونوا على علم بطبيعه المرض الذي
يواجهونه لقد كان مخيفا جدا وكل فرد من
الفريق الطبي شعر بمسؤوليه كبيره لانه كان
لدينا اكثر من 100 مريض مصاب بمرض السارس
وعاده ما يحاول الناس اعطاء لمسه عاطفيه
لتجاربهم الا ان الحادثه شكلت صدمه للجميع
وانا لا اعتبر نفسي بطلا لانني تدربت على
التعامل مع الالتهاب الرئوي وهذا هو
عملي ووفقا للمركز الامريكي للسيطره على
الامراض فان مرض سارز توقف في عام
2004 الا ان تداعياته لا تزال تظهر في
هونغ كونج الى اليوم فهناك اللافتات
بمواعيد التق على المباني اضافه الى
انتشار معقمات اليد الفوريه في الشوارع
وعند مرض احد سكان المنطقه تنتشر الاقنعه
بين الناس لتجنب انتقاله لباقي
السكان وتعبر كاثي عن سعادتها وسرورها
لانتشار الوعي بين الناس مضيفه ان ضحايا
سارز لا يزالون يتعالجون بعضهم جسديا
والبعض الاخر
معنويا لطالما قلت لنفسي ان الامور على ما
يرام فقد تعافيت وانتهى المرض والكارثه
انتهت ايضا فبالفعل الحظ كان
حليفي